[Musique]
de retour sur le plateau des débats des
départementales sur france 3 bourgogne
comme promis on s'intéresse désormais à
la nièvre et pour débattre sont avec
nous ce soir carole boirin des
républicains bonsoir également avec nous
blandine de laporte ex ps aujourd'hui
membre du mouvement générations pour
soir bonsoir
également jean-luc gauthier chef de file
un groupe réunissant des candidats
divers droite et différence entre
bonsoir bonsoir
wilfrid séjeau d'europe écologie les
verts bonsoir ça est également damien
beaudry du rassemblement national
bonsoir bonsoir on va s'intéresser donc
tout d'abord au contexte politique de
cette élection
et puis je vous propose tout de suite
aidé pour débuter de regarder la
composition de l'assemblée sortante de
ce conseil départemental de la nièvre où
le groupe socialiste était donc
largement majoritaires blanc t-il de la
porte de tourner vers vous puisque vous
êtes 10 présidente sortante vous
représentez la la majorité en place
le parti socialiste dirigeant fait ce
département depuis 1964 et lorsqu'on
écoute actuellement les observateurs et
les commentateurs ils disent que jamais
votre famille politique n'a été aussi
menacé dans quel état d'esprit vous
abordé cette élection est ce que vous
partagez ce constat alors déjà ce n'est
pas la même majorité qu'en 1964 parce
que ce sont pas les mêmes personnes
ce sont des majorités de gauche
effectivement d'une certaine sensibilité
qui se sont succédé il n'y avait pas que
des socialistes est aussi des
communistes des divers gauche pas que
des socialistes est aujourd'hui des
générations comme moi par exemple
donc ce n'est pas la même majorité qui
se répète depuis 1964 la disponibilité
en attendant c'est la petite musique
qu'on entend depuis depuis quelques
semaines et c'est au contraire nous
sommes dans le renouvellement seulement
candidats qui sont aujourd'hui candidats
au départemental et qui était déjà en
place se représente et 15 nouveaux
nouveaux visages nouvelles idées
nouvelles personnalités
donc on est aussi dans le renouvellement
ça veut dire que cet argument 60 ans ça
suffit ça vous ça vous fait peur vous
avez peur d'une certaine usure du
pouvoir
mais c'est surtout 60 ans de choix des
nivernais donc quand on critique le
choix des nivernais
on critique les nivernais et on n'arrête
pas de leur dire vous avez fait le
mauvais choix pendant 60 ans c'est leur
choix
et donc quand on critique leur choix ce
sont les nivernais qu'on prend pour des
imbéciles
jean-luc gauthier vous vous êtes de lire
la traduction est le chef de file d'une
liste de candidats d'union entre divers
droite et divers centres et soutenue par
la république en marche
j'ai lu sur le compte facebook de votre
groupe la nièvre ensemble que vous vous
agace y ait à ce que l'on serve ça vous
coller cette étiquette delà de la
république en marche on a l'impression
que c'est presque un soutien gênant pour
vous c'est inexact surtout parce que la
nièvre ensemble qu'est ce que c'est
l'avenir ensemble c'est le prolongement
de la nièvre s'engage qui s'était
présenté aux élections en 2015 la nièvre
s'engage aujourd'hui c'est l'opposition
de la droite et du centre au sein du
conseil départemental nous avons
renouvelé nos équipes nous les avons
énergie nous sommes enrichis par des
femmes et des hommes qui apporte une
nouvelle énergie de nouvelles
compétences et en fait nous avons
construit nos listes comme construit une
liste aux élections municipales
quand on sollicite quelqu'un on
sollicite pas pour son ancrage politique
et pour sa capacité à travailler en
équipe à faire avancer le territoire et
surtout il faut qu on partage le même
constat est le même bilan
nous notre ligne est notre cap n'a pas
changé nous pensons contrairement à ce
que dit madame de la porte que ce
département est mal gérée et c'est ça
qui nous réunit ici nous avons rêvé sur
l'étiquette politique
arrêtez moi si je me trompe peut être de
nature you était bien présent au moment
de le
'l'annonce des minots qui se portait
candidat non non denis thuriau n'était
pas présent à ce moment là ils sont
faits une conférence de presse et que
monsieur bergé voilà après la république
en marche comme unique comme elle
l'entend nous en tout cas nous ne la
veut dire que vous êtes soutenus à vos
dépends par la république commandées par
soutien aux dépens toutes celles et tous
ceux qui se reconnaissent dans notre
ligne de notre cap sont les bienvenus
si la république en marche adhèrent à
notre ligne est notre cap qui existe
depuis longtemps c'est pas quelque chose
qui sort du panier
nous nous en réjouissons et puis je
voudrais simplement dire quand même
parce que madame de la porte a dit conte
si on critiquer la majorité actuelle
monsieur bazin dit qu'on dénigre la
nièvre maintenant nous nous sommes
passionnément nivernais moi j'y suis né
j'y vis et je compte y rester
et donc si on ceci on critique le sien
en critiquant le bilan on nous reproche
de dénigrer la nièvre ça c'est assez
révélateur d'une certaine image me me
semble-t-il de la façon dont il ils
envisagent leur mandat le il aime le mil
de l'ambiance et de la bid on va
vraiment l'évoqué on a largement le
temps de fréquenter des minutes donc on
va pouvoir les bons textes c'est quand
est ce qu'on va les vocalises et alors
il s'est simplement ils aiment daniel
nous l'aimons aussi et ils n'ont pas le
monopole de la nièvre tout simplement on
va en parler les gens tendent à
démontrer 40 voire un vous cette liste
de candidats proposés par dont fait
partie de ce boîtier vous vous n'avez
pas souhaité avoir la même démarche
alors je faisais partie de la nièvre
s'engage il y a 6 ans je suis resté tel
que je suis l air et avec un binôme qui
est qui n'est pas l air qui est divers
droite
en revanche je n'ai pas souhaité mme
allier à la république en marche
effectivement puisque denis thuriau a
quand même annoncé avant même que les
binômes ne s'annoncent eux mêmes qu'il
avait 17 candidats lrm et ses dix sept
candidats sont représentés aujourd'hui
par monsieur gautier donc un jeune et je
n'ai
je n'ai pas souhaité adhérer à cela
chacun est libre de ses un retournement
et de ses volontés je suis restée la
même et je n'ai pas voulu adhérer à l
air m voilà donc vous allez le breton je
suis ouverte c'est pas c'est pas une
question d'ouverture ou de ne pas
ouverture c'est d'avoir une politique
qui est constante aux yeux des électeurs
mais du coup ça veut dire que vous
proposez des binômes face à des
candidats des amis de monsieur gautier
avec peut-être le risque de faire gagner
la gauche
alors la question ne se pose pas comme
ça en ce qui me concerne je suis un
départ conseillère départementale
sortante et crm qui a donc présenté un
candidat contre moi non
donc je la question se pose ainsi dans
mon canton
non monsieur cordier est adhérent au bel
air voilà c'est ce qui est une réalité
il n'est pas aidé rue m il est adhérent
au bel air dont sa carte a été renvoyée
probable je suis malade voire exact bon
alors que vous craignez pas qu'elles
étaient renvoyés à monsieur corps
d'huile a été remboursé de ses
cotisations
bon mais bon on est d'accord mais votre
démarche madame madame barras et une
opposition va dire frontale on va non
pas du tout on va imaginer par d'autres
le troisième tour si par exemple vous on
va dire que vos votes voici votre binôme
l'emportent pouvait faire basculer d'un
côté ou de l'autre vous faites quoi la
présidence de l'assemblée
alors la question ne se pose pas comme
ça en ce qui me concerne la question
c'est quelle politique va mener lrm si
jamais ils ont ils ont 8 8 1 et que je
suis là disent que je suis la 17e la
question se pose ainsi parce que la
politique c'est pas une question de
personne la nièvre ensemble c'est bien
on est tous contents on est tous amis
mais c'est pas la question la question
c'est quelle politique demain pour la
nièvre et à l'heure d'aujourd'hui dans
les tracts que je vois pour lr eux mêmes
je n'ai pas de programme donc si elle
est même un programme imaginons qu'il
soit 8 1 et 8 binôme et que je sois
celle qui fait peser la balance tout
dépend du programme
moi je ne me détermine par fonction
d'une vacance à n'avait pas d'avis
arrêté encore pour là on va parler tout
à l'heure a de quoi faire demain on va
continuer un petit peu le tour de cette
table avec
fritz et joe vous votre candidature ce
n'est clairement pas une candidature
d'opposition au ps non c'est une
candidature de propositions nous pensons
qu'un simple de choses doivent évoluer
au sein du conseil départemental
effectivement que ce conseil
départemental doit mieux représenter la
société que des écologistes peuvent y
rentrer des communistes des gens divers
gauche des gens de la société civile
nous voulons donner des couleurs à ce
conseil départemental et contribuer au
renouvellement dont a parlé blandine
pour lui donner un nouveau souffle et
apporter des nouvelles propositions
donc nous notre souhait est
effectivement c'est que ce département
soit gérée par une majorité regroupant
la gauche et les écologistes
et puis se transforme et les politiques
publiques et répondre aux attentes
moi mon souhait titre personnel c'est
d'éviter que madame boivin et d4
conscience à se poser puisque nous
sommes candidats sur le même canton et
que nous espérons bien l'emporter ce qui
pourrait éventuellement simplifier cette
décision parce que on l'a vu il ya une
ambiguïté ou en tout cas ce n'est pas
très clair au niveau de l'eau de
l'étiquette on va dire de la liste de
monsieur gautier c'est vous c'est pas
très clair non plus vous avez créé un
groupe nièvre écologie et solidaire vous
vous présentez sur douze cantons vous
êtes allié avec le ps c'est votre cas
dans votre compte ou d'ailleurs dans 5
et vous êtes en candidature concurrente
dans les sept autres est ce que vous
croyez pas que tout ça c'est un petit
peu trouble pour les lecteurs alors nous
clairement nous aurions préféré qu'un
accord départemental que ce soit le plus
lisible possible pour les électeurs
ensuite moi j'ai un tempérament à voir
le verre plutôt à moitié plein et il ya
six ans il y avait aucune espèce
d'alliance l'alliance sur plusieurs
cantons sur 50 ans dont certains cantons
qui sont en jeu qui sont à risque où il
ya un risque également par exemple de
front national donc nous progressons et
nous espérons de toute façon de pouvoir
construire une majorité pour la suite
damien beaudry au rassemblement national
pas d'alliance je vous êtes présent dans
tous les cantons en 2015 vous aviez au
second tour dépassé les 40% sur deux
d'entre eux deux c'est aussi nos efforts
sont beaux quels sont vos objets nous
vers le pardon sur nevers 2 et
fourchambault fonctions et nevers de
pardo quelles sont vos ambitions sur ce
scrutin là nos ambitions sont de rentrer
dans l'assemblée départementale
ce qu il est clair qu'aujourd'hui il
faut changer radicalement de politique
qui a été mise en place
on voit ici que tout que tout le monde
du moins là la représentante du parti
socialiste et le représentant des drm
qui se cache derrière un tract sans
étiquette et qui n'assument pas leur
héritage politique la gauche est bien
contente de féliciter deux présidents
présidents pour prendre la suite du
conseil départemental
sans critiquer une seule fois le bilan
précédent et la candidature dit de
droite macro nist est aujourd'hui un peu
d'eux de ce soutien mais il est là il
est bien réelle mais vous pensez que
seul pouvait y arriver
pourquoi on ne pourrait pas y arriver le
contrat qu'on passe nous l'alliance
qu'on passe aujourd'hui c'est avec les
électeurs on n'a pas d'accord d'appareil
de big bear où chacun sont pour en
désaccord total dans leur programme dans
leurs programmes locaux mais demain
feront une alliance au département tout
ça pour pour avoir une place bien merci
pour ce petit tour de table sur le
contexte politico va maintenant passer
aux premiers thèmes que nous avons
choisi pour ce débat celui de comment
stopper l'érosion démographique et pour
l'introduire et bien je vous propose de
regarder ces chiffres les chiffres de la
population de ce département de la
nièvre en 2012 l'insee estimé à 2 116
1786 211 1747 en 2015 et en 2018 205
lindsay qui estime qu'en moyenne ce
département perd 0,9 pour cent de sa
population
chaque année c'est là la chute la plus
lourde a envie de dire de population
blandine de la porte à cela dit vous
êtes 10 président sortant que je me
tourne vers vous ce phénomène il
apparaît sans incident date depuis de
longues années et malgré tout durant 7 6
dernières années
vous n'avez pas su stopper pourquoi
c'est inévitable non c'est pas
inévitable simplement je crois que on le
constate effectivement on a un
département où les personnes âgées sont
les plus représentés et donc on a un
solde naturel qui est qui est en berne
il ya moins de naissances que de décès
cela étant dit on voit quand même et la
crise du coc vide nous l'a montré
on voit qu'il y a quand même quelques
lueurs d'espoir dans ces chiffres que
vous nous montrez c'est justement ces
citadins qui ont envie de retrouver un
peu
vie à la campagne ils ont un peu mieux
découvert peut-être nos territoires
pendant la pandémie les les opérateurs
téléphoniques nous disent que 9000
personnes sont venues se confiner dans
la nièvre
au cours du premier confinement donc
c'est tout à fait possible d'attirer ils
restent de plus en plus longtemps c'est
à dire que ce qu'ils avaient comme
maison secondaire et il venait un week
end tous les six mois
ils y viennent plus régulièrement et là
ils finissent par se partager le temps
on voit bien que pour attirer ces gens
il faut des médecins il faut le très
haut débit pour le pour le télétravail
il faut un monde associatif un monde
culturel sportif qui soit foisonnant
pour pouvoir donner de l'activité
il faut des collèges et des écoles à
proximité pour attirer des familles par
exemple pierre lebrun vous partager ce
constat et cet optimisme après ce que
j'ai envie de dire jusque là le discours
a un peu changé quand même parce que
jusqu'à là dans le au sein de
l'assemblée départementale le discours
qui nous étaient servis pour dire que la
population diminue elle c'était de dire
que nous n'étions pas ni à côté de
l'atlantique ni à côté de la
méditerranée et que nous étions dans la
diagonale du vide
la belle affaire c'est vrai que c'est un
département qui est très rurale et 30%
de la population a plus de 60 ans 15%
plus de 75
le vrai défi de ce département c'est de
maintenir les jeunes dans notre
département les jeunes qui font des
études parts et les jeunes qui ne font
pas d'études
30% d'entre eux n'ont aucune
qualification et se retrouvent soit avec
le rsa lorsqu'ils ont la possibilité
d'en avoir un soit en grande difficulté
donc le vrai défi de ce département
c'est de maintenir sa jeunesse sur le
territoire
voilà à travers l'emploi à travers la
forme mais sur les six années passées on
a fait ce qu'il fallait un nom personne
n'a fait ce qu'il fallait d'ailleurs
parce que lrm les candidats est la même
aujourd'hui qui disent que la population
diminue alors on est call it n'est pas
n'est pas
n'est pas à la mairie de nevers mais la
mairie nevers depuis qu'elle est là et
depuis bas non vous représentez la
peinture y est là depuis 6 ans et la
population ne cesse de diminuer nous
perdons quand même 1000 milles habitants
par an donc c'est vraiment
catastrophique nous sommes le
département de france qui a le plus
perdu en population c'est ce que dit le
rapport de la chambre régionale des
comptes
donc il ya vraiment une érosion qui ne
s'explique pas par le fait que nous ne
sommes pas à côté de la mer où nous ne
sommes pas dans la diagonale du vide
nous sommes le département le qui est le
plus impacté par la population me
beaudry votre constat vous n'aurait pu
faire mieux on aurait pu limiter cette
érosion démographique
je pense surtout qu'avant de vouloir
attirer de nouveaux habitants
l'important c'est déjà de garder prendre
soin des nivernais qui habite le
département parce que il vous faut
donner hull en vie et la fierté aux gens
d'habiter la nièvre ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui nous avons des paysages
une nature un terroir idyllique mais à
son inverse le département n'est pas
rentré au 21ème siècle nous avons pas
mis en oeuvre toutes ces possibilités
d'avoir les audi a manqué alors mais ce
qu'il a manqué c'est d'être de ne plus
avoir de zone blanche sur le département
d'avoir un réseau internet qu'ils soient
au point sur l'intégralité du
département avoir une politique
d'attractivité pour les entreprises
d'avoir des antilles citation fiscal par
exemple pour les entreprises avoir un
réseau routier à digne de ce nom et
ensuite pour aussi pour les écoles et le
maintien d'un service public pour déjà
gardé les habitants prendre soin des
nivernais et des nivernais et leur
donner cette fierté d'habiter dans notre
département
monsieur gautier vous diriez la même
chose on n'a pas fait assez
pratiquement c'est clairement l'échec
c'est un constat d'échec pour la
majorité en place
c'est pas agréable à entendre mais c'est
pourtant la vérité alors que nous avons
beaucoup d'atouts la nièvre est belle ça
a été dit daniel vrai bien situer
géographiquement au centre de la france
ça coûte quand même pas très cher de
venir s'installer dans le département
l'immobilier et à un prix relativement
modeste et raisonnée pareil pour
l'immobilier d'entreprise et malgré ça
on n'arrive pas à tirer alors
effectivement les infrastructures
routières sont laissés à l'abandon il
faut quand même le dire on ne sait pas
s'appuyer non plus sur les compétences
on a un réseau de chefs d'entreprise qui
est relativement important et dense
appuyons nous sur ces gens là parce que
ils ont des collègues dans d'autres
départements qui quelquefois cherchent à
s'installer et qui pourrait trouver dans
notre département des lieux idylliques
pour le faire et puis nos jeunes nos
jeunes n'ont pas beaucoup d'avenir
avec mon épouse nous avons six enfants
sur les six qui n'a qu'un qui va rester
dans le département ce qu'il est
agriculteur tous les autres sont partis
étudier ailleurs et ils vont s'installer
ailleurs
donc on peut pas continuer comme ça la
santé de la santé c'est un facteur un
facteur d'attractivité évident nous
avons des déserts médicaux
alors bien sûr des choses positives qui
ont été faites et je le dis quand elle
quand c'est le cas et la bourse pour les
médecins c'est important
c'est bien il faut l'amplifier il faut
aller sur tous les métiers etc et qui
ont les autres et à la santé qui sont en
tension
il faut continuer dans ce sens là le
tourisme le tourisme est inexploitée
sous-exploité nos paysages où les dix
sont magnifiques
il faut que quelqu'un qui arrive en gare
de nevers ont guère de caunes prenne ses
valises ses chaussures de randonnée et
soit capable de traverser ce département
en sachant là où il pourra manger là il
pourra dormir pour pouvoir découvrir
notre territoire et envie d'y avoir
envie d'y revenir et de pas de le faire
savoir à ses collègues au travail par la
suite ou fcg au boulot sur ses six ans
passés vos fait un constat aussi les
gatti fou non moi ce qui m'intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est de parler de
propositions
on a parlé de la démographie médicale la
situation extrêmement préoccupante
puisque il ya 50% des médecins qui
exercent aujourd'hui dans la nef qui ont
plus de 60 ans donc là il faut trouver
des solutions et nous ce qu'on propose
par exemple à l'instar de ce qui s'est
fait en saône et loire qui n'est pas de
la même couleur politique mais quand les
idées sont bonnes nous sommes les
premiers à reconnaître ils ont embauché
des médecins salariés ça je pense que
c'est une mesure utile
on pense qu'il faut aussi mieux
valoriser la nièvre mieux faire
connaître ses atouts atouts
environnementaux atouts culturels aussi
on a une vie culturelle extrêmement
riche dans le département je pense qu'il
faut faire du marketing territorial
c'est un mot qu'on emploie beaucoup mais
en l'occurrence sur ces thèmes-là les
promouvoir
on pense que sur les transports il faut
aussi améliorer les liaisons
ferroviaires notamment nevers paris
nevers dijon et des gros travail à gros
travail à faire et puis nous on veut
aussi recréer de l'emploi recréer de
l'économie notamment à partir des
richesses effectivement du territoire en
relocalisant l'économie mais en
développant les circuits courts en
soutenant nos producteurs nos
agriculteurs nos paysans en valorisant
toutes ses productions de qualité qui
font aussi la richesse de notre
département
mais on permettant aussi de les
transformer sur place parce que c'est en
transformant sur place qu'on crée de la
valeur ajoutée qu on crée de l'emploi
je pense qu'il faut pas opposer
nivernais de souche ou nouveaux
arrivants tout ce qu'on améliorera en
termes de santé publique d'économie
d'école servira à tout le monde
le second oui simplement quelque chose
d'essentiel
c'est que nous n'avons pas les moyens de
nous disperser et il n'est pas normal il
n'est pas raisonnable d'avoir d'un côté
l'agglo les comcom et le département
il faut que nous travaillons la main
dans la main et le rôle du département
sera d'unir toutes les sensibilités
parce qu'une fois élu l'arbitré a sifflé
la fin de la partie froid qu'on
travaille et ça sera plus facile parce
que tiens j'ai une question pour madame
de la porte je suis là les lèvres je
suis la nièvre qu'est-ce que ça devient
quel bilan
on sait que ça coûtait quelques
centaines de milliers d'euros mais pour
quel résultat
6-6 autour de trois cent mille euros
dont il faut quand même parce que chacun
a fait sa place dans le département
il faut l'espérer pour madame de la
porte le nom absolument pas ça a coûté
une subvention de 50 mille euros de
départ pour travailler sur cette
question de je suis la nièce de ce
marketing territorial et effectivement
nous avons voulu confier entre
guillemets les clés du camion à la
société civile et aux acteurs
économiques et nous avons constaté que
ça n'allait pas suffisamment vite et
donc c'est aujourd'hui l' agence de
développement touristique qui s'est vu
chargé de l'attractivité également et
qui aujourd'hui et agences
d'attractivité du département donc voilà
perdu quelques années malgré tout et
tout ça pour eux alors je dis pas que
les tories mais pour forcément très les
forces vives du territoire
c'est ça c'était important je regrette
que l'agglo et le département ne
travaillent pas ensemble
l'agglo a rush de noël sur al 2006 on a
une position raisonnable lors ce qui me
concerne d'accord
l'agglo a refusé de participer à je suis
la nièvre du jour de rappel lors d'une
de la porte aux parlait du togo ce cesu
en parler des médecins de la
problématique des médecins vous aviez
optez donc pour cette stratégie de
donner des bourses les nivernais
oui vous proposé par contre cette fois
de passer à une autre étape avec les
médecins salariés vous rejoignez notre
séjour absolument ont rejoint la
proposition qui a été faite par mon
voisin effectivement de salariés des
médecins en lien avec les maisons de
santé qui maillent le territoire elles
se sont considérablement développés
et puis nous voulons également mettre en
place un centre départemental de soins
qui dans le même temps sera amené à
faire de la prévention du dépistage de
la vaccination on voit à quel point ça a
été nécessaire sur ces derniers mois
cette dernière année donc voilà oui
salariés des médecins et puis et puis
continuer ces bourses d'études pour les
jeunes médecins
les maîtres les proposer à de jeunes
dentistes parce que c'est très compliqué
aussi trouver un dentiste dans la nièvre
actuellement et puis on parlera
certainement aussi des ophtalmos
pourquoi pas des génies co monsieur
baudrier votre votre avis sur la
question deux pour lutter contre le
salariat des médecins pourquoi pas j'ai
envie de dire de toute façon faut
essayer de mettre tout ce qui est en
oeuvre pour sortir le département de
de ce désert médical après oui des
choses peuvent être faites en payant une
partie voire l'intégralité des études de
médecine et de spécialités et avec un
accord derrière que ces jeunes
s'installent sur au moins pourquoi pas
cinq ou dix ans sous peine de devoir
rembourser au conseil départemental
l'intégralité de cette avance pourquoi
pas j'ai envie de dire après l'arrivée
de nouveaux médecins
je pense qu'elle est ni de droite ni de
gauche et c'est d'un intérêt à
nécessaire pour le département et il
faut qu'on réfléchisse tous ensemble à
une solution pour pour sortir la nièvre
de ce désert médical
madame voire à la même chose même pour
la libérale que vous êtes ya pas de
souci avec le salariat des médecins
alors c'est pas moi qui commande sur ce
point c'est à dire que chaque médecin
chaque candidat médecins se disent il
veut être salarié ou pas salarié c'est
pas ça ne décrète pas en fait ce genre
de choses on peut pas dire alors on peut
dire qu'on va recruter des médecins
salariés et si une personne veut être
salarié et bien tant mieux enfin moi j'y
vois pas d'inconvénient je suis libéral
sur ce point effectivement ce que le
président l'a su je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord souvent avec monsieur l'assumer
monsieur lassus le président actuel du
conseil départemental socialiste qui est
annoncé un médecin a bien fait les
choses il faut le dire c'est le seul
point peut-être sur lequel il a bien
fait les choses mais de les a bien fait
parce que il a donné des bourses aux
médecins nous venons de voter des
bourses pour les dentistes dans la
mesure où nous n'avons plus plus
beaucoup de dentistes et les bourses
sont étendues aux étudiants mais
dentiste ce que le président l'a su qui
est médecin et regrettait c'est qu'avec
le salariat il y à un risque que nous
attirions vers notre département des
médecins en fin de vie professionnelle
et qu'ils souhaitent un petit peu
terminer tranquillement et donc que nous
développions des territoires qui sont
déjà en manque de médecins pour faire
venir chez nous des salariés favorisons
les jeunes médecins favorisons ce se qui
s'implante à travers les bourses
ça me semble une meilleure solution eh
bien merci on va arrêter là pour leur
dernier mot monsieur gaultier parce que
vous êtes vous êtes vous êtes en avance
sur le temps de parole de vraiment très
rapidement réagi en suis en avance est
parfait
c'est une solution c'est pas la solution
c'est une solution et qu'il faut garder
les territoires où ça fonctionne bien à
saint bénin d'azy on a cette chance là
et il faut surtout inciter à mon avis
les médecins à devenir maître de stage
pour essayer de fidéliser des stagiaires
qui viendraient voir découvrir daniel
merci d'avoir été bref on arrête donc là
pour ce premier thème on va aborder le
deuxième dans un instant mais juste
avant on passe aux questions flash j'ai
des questions flash de que des questions
rapide et précise à laquelle on vous a
demandé de répondre rapidement en une
phrase si possible pour la première on
va commencer donc vous n'avez pas eu
madame de la porte c'est ça et ben voilà
et bien vous allez devoir donc en direct
aurait pourtant dû se fera ce sera un
peu le tennis pour vous laisser un peu
de temps du coup on va commencer par
monsieur gautier on va faire le tour de
la table dans ce sens là monsieur
gautier limitations de vitesse ce qu'il
faut maintenir à 80 km/heure ou est-ce
qu'il faut revenir aux 90 il faut
revenir à 90 km heure chaque fois que
c'est possible et on fait en
concertation avec les maires qui eux
connaissent leur territoire et
connaissent les routes qui sont à sites
accidentogènes ou dangereuses la dame
voir la même chose je pense qu'il faut
revenir aux 90 km/heure la mesure était
destinée à être temporaires et à être
revu elle n'a pas été revue et tous les
territoires ruraux qui ont comme nous à
850 km de routes sont pour le retour ou
90 km de chez beaudry retour aux 90 km
heure contrairement à l'avis de la
gauche départementale
monsieur ces jo 350 vies sauvées avec 80
km heure
donc je pense qu'il faut faire preuve de
pragmatisme on peut l'envisager sur
certaines routes mais moi la sécurité
routière c'est vraiment une de mes
priorités
blandine de la porte il y a ceux qui
font des choix en conscience et d'autres
paille ceux qui font des choix
électoraliste et d'autres pas oui
revenons à 90 km/heure sur des axes très
ciblées et en appliquant les mesures
préconisées par la sécurité routière
deuxième question le département touati
c'était vrai soeur la règle du jeu
monsieur boutry c'était vraiment en une
phrase deuxième question le département
doit-il se porter candidat pour
expérimenter le rsa jeune monsieur ces
jo puis monsieur beaudry oui oui je
pense que les 18 25 ans ont été
extrêmement
frappés par la crise du coville beaucoup
de jeunes n'ont aucune solution l'emploi
des jeunes c'est compliqué même s'il ya
des mesures qui ont été pris par le
gouvernement
donc oui pour cette expérimentation non
je pense que les jeunes n'ont pas besoin
du rsa mais ils ont besoin d'emplois et
c'est la politique du pire quand quand
nos élus baissent les bras et propose
d'une certaine façon une sorte
d'assistanat aux jeunes madame boira
puis madame de la porte
alors je pense que philosophiquement la
réponse est non
parce que ce dont ont besoin les jeunes
c'est effectivement d'un d'une promesse
d'avenir de travail d'une formation
j'ai conscience que les jeunes ont
beaucoup souffert avec la pandémie et
que les étudiants notamment mais pas
qu'eux ont beaucoup souffert également
et que leurs ressources sont diminués
mais l'espoir c'est mieux que
l'assistanat c'est d'autant plus à fait
au point mort c'est à temps c'est
d'autant mieux qu'à l'heure actuelle il
existe des aides très importantes des
gens pour les hommes les jeunes et
notamment les jeunes étudiants qui
lorsqu'ils ont la bourse ont
pratiquement un montant de rs 1 voilà
madame de la porte l'espoir c'est bien
mais ça donne pas à manger 1 et savent
où logent pas donc oui au rsa jeunes et
à l'expérimentation
parce que malheureusement les jeunes
n'ont pas d'autres aides que les
allocations logement
monsieur gautier euh non ça doit rester
l'exception et quelqu'un qui a besoin
qu'un accident de la vie bien entendu
qu'il faut l'aider mais les jeunes je
pense qu'ils ont besoin d'un travail
permis de conduire un travail et pouvoir
construire une vie et se sentir utile
dans la société
question suivante quelle à ces
oscillations au sein du rpt
l'association quel type d'association
faut-il subventionnés en priorité
monsieur beaudry puis madame boirin les
associations savent être toutes celles
qui font le rayonnement de la nièvre qui
favorise son patrimoine quel type
d'association d'une phrase tout et
associations autour pour la rénovation
et l'entretien et la promotion du
patrimoine à hiverner madame voir
sportives et culturelles ce qui peut
aider les jeunes à sortir de chez eux à
s'ouvrir au monde je pense que c'est
très important
le second pied puis madame de la pop
sociaux les bénévoles dans ces
associations font un travail formidable
il faut qu'ils soient soutenus
encouragés donc si je devais faire un
choix ça se respire handicap et les
refuges animaliers qui répare bien
souvent la conséquence des citoyens
toutes les associations qui qui
permettent le vivre ensemble et la
cohésion sociale donc je dirai
évidemment environnement sport culture
je pense que le rôle d'un politique
c'est d'examiner des projets c'est
d'examiner des dossiers lors nos
nouveaux priorité c'est bien sûr le
culture la culture le sport
l'environnement mais un élu doit
examiner un dossier et évaluer sa
pertinence on n'est pas là pour répartir
l'argent public n'importe comment
et puis enfin dernière question flash
tourisme quel est l'atout numéro 1 en
matière de tourisme du département
monsieur c'est joe lo et les vélos la
loire le canal latéral à la loire le
canal du nivernais tout ça à vélo ou à
pied sur ces boîtiers son patrimoine
qu'il soit paysagers ou ou bâti c'est
pour ça qu'il faut accompagner les
communes quand celle de le soutenir leur
leur patrimoine qui est quelquefois
s'était mise en débat par la majorité
départementale
et puis n'oublions jamais que les
paysages ils sont façonnés par ceux qui
travaillent donc les agriculteurs nous
l'oublions jamais monsieur baudry le
tourisme vert le morvan soutenir toutes
les initiatives qui peuvent aller dans
ce sens dans ce développement ou qui est
très riche en quatorze emplois aussi
madame de la porte puis je vais me
permettre une pointe de chauvinisme et
je vais dire le prieuré de la charité
très bien je vais me permettent
également une pointe de chauvinisme avec
le palais ducal la cathédrale et es15
bernadette pas fair play on avait dit
qu'on parlait du par département dans
son ensemble on va passer maintenant
donc à notre deuxième thème et on va se
poser la question de quelle gestion de
la collectivité puisque en 2019 la
chambre la chambre régionale des comptes
dans son action de contrôle a rendu un
rapport sur la gestion du département
dans ses conclusions elle pointe une
difficile maîtrise des frais de
fonctionnement notamment en matière de
personnel je propose de regarder
d'ailleurs ce chiffre selon ce rapport
les dépenses de personnel ont augmenté
de 15% entre 2012 et 2018
et je crois que ça continuait à m'ôter
depuis carole boirin d'ailleurs déjà
dans le dans l'assemblée vous
vite y est déjà intervenu sur cette
question oui ce qui est très embêtant au
niveau du personnel les dépenses de
personnel ont beaucoup pour augmenter
pendant la dernière mandature mais ce
qui est le plus inquiétant c'est que le
personnel à travailler moins que les
heure légale bénéficient de primes aux
noms obscurs
par exemple la prime du président la
prime
il ya des noms pour toutes les primes ce
qui permet d'éviter peut-être un peu le
droit du travail pour l'assemblée
départementale et à travers et des
journées de congé aussi pour les raisons
les plus diverses par exemple
déménagement d'un frère ou d'une soeur
le décès d'un frère ou d'une soeur
donc il faut revenir à ce qui à la
légalité ne pas avoir de mesures
électoralisme avec le personnel d'abord
parce que tout le personnel doit être
traité de la même façon et pas en
fonction de ce qu'il peut apporter à la
majorité en place
monsieur ces jo votre avis dans ce
domaine de la gestion du personnel il ya
un problème ou pas au conseil
départemental de la nièvre
je pense qu'il faut effectivement
examiner tout cela mais moi je voudrait
élargir un peu le propos parce que on
est quand même dans une situation où les
finances des collectivités locales sont
sont misent quasiment sous tutelle par
l'état elles n'ont plus de marge de
manoeuvre dans les programmes de
certains concurrents il a indiqué qu'il
faut arrêter d'augmenter la fiscalité
sur le sur le foncier bâti
or le département n'a pu cette
compétence il ne peut plus il ne peut
plus quasiment levée d'impôts a peint
les droits de mutation donc on est
arrivé à un système où l'ensemble des
collectivités locales n'a plus aucune
marge de manoeuvre
et ça je trouve ça extrêmement
préoccupant après les citoyens jugent
ils sont pour contre la hausse des
impôts là toute façon le département ne
peut plus ni augmenter ni vu la liste
des règles fiscales c'est la même dans
tous les départements de france oui mais
c'est rare compte cette gestion des
ressources du mail du conseil
départemental de la nièvre allait plutôt
particulière est ce que vous la soutenez
ou pas qu'il faut changer quelque chose
de pas moi je pense qu'il faudrait
examiner ça de près et oui mais pour
vous il ya problème ou non je pense que
c'est un essai site une analyse un peu
plus approfondie que juste qui a été mis
dans le rapport de la cour des comptes
qui en général a quand même des rapports
qui sont relativement à charge pour les
collectivités veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que pour vous plus 15 % de frais de
personnel
ça peut se justifier il ya des missions
qui sont développés il y à un
accompagnement social qui est de plus en
plus croissants et plus en plus
d'attributaires du rsa il ya de plus
amples
deux personnes âgées en perte
d'autonomie donc je crois qu'on peut pas
faire d'électoralisme sur ce sujet il
faut voir les besoins des nids berné
comme on y répond lors de la porte vous
laisse peut-être défendre ce bilan oui
alors quand même les dépenses totales de
fonctionnement sur la dernière mandature
nous augmenté que de 0,4 pour cent donc
évidemment les frais de personnel et
wilfrid séjeau l'a rappelé avec des d un
accompagnement social qui doit être au
plus près des tributaires des minima
sociaux avec un accompagnement des
personnes âgées des personnes
handicapées avec des assistantes
familiales de plus en plus nombreuses
pour accueillir les enfants qui sont
confiées au département bref évidemment
des personnels qui sont en augmentation
et des missions qui nous sont fixés de
plus en plus nombreuses
l'explosion des dépenses de
fonctionnement on l'a vu aussi à
l'agglomération à la ville de nevers à
la ville de connell la communauté de
communes coeur de loire donc c'est pas
le département qui est seule en cause
par ailleurs le département à maîtriser
son endettement
et cette année propose 40 millions
budget de 40 millions d'investissements
sur sur son patrimoine sur ces routes
et c'est donc un effort considérable
donc non la gestion du département est
maîtrisé et et et en plus elle et elle
était contrainte pendant un temps par ce
fameux pacte de cahors seuls les
départements d'ailleurs été concernés
par ce pacte de chaos rhin où il fallait
maîtriser absolument alors on vous
ramène rapidement celle de la volonté de
l'état de limite est de faire en sorte
que les goûts à l'invité limite
l'augmentation de leurs frais de
fonctionnement à la ville de pourtant
qui proposait de contractualiser aux
collectivités ce que vous n'avez pas
fait d'ailleurs nous n'avons pas signé
mais nous nous sommes appliqués la règle
histoire de pas être rap
chauffer si personnel si je ne me trompe
et les dépenses de personnel ont
augmenté pendant la durée sur la durée
examiné par la chambre régionale des
comptes de 18 % 34 % pour les seules
femmes et assistants familiaux donc il
faut rester dans nos gènes de cet
objectif
oui monsieur beaudry votre votre avis à
vous sur cette gestion de la
collectivité
je pense qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'il
faut changer cette façon de faire et on
parle et là des charges de personnel
avec les assistants familiaux qui ont
augmenté mais elles ont augmenté aussi
avec l'arrivée des migrants non
accompagnés
c'est à cette un coût pour la
collectivité sur lequel on aurait pu se
passer et puis que avec le rassemblement
national allait défiler par l'état dont
on aurait pu se passer d'une action
mondiale
c'est des choix c'est des volontés
politiques auront alors il nous fallait
des politiques papa au niveau du
département au choix un niveau et
attention c'est pas pour l'hébergement
l'hébergement on a le choix entre les
familles d'accueil et on a le choix
entre les hôtels le département la
majorité départementale avait choisi
dans un premier temps les familles
d'accueil ça s'est pas très bien passé
pas très bien dans les familles
d'accueil parce que les migrants
arrivent souvent quand même ils ont au
delà de 15 ans et ils ont donc âgé ça se
passe pas de sait pas très bien dans les
familles d'accueil
on a donc décidé de les mettre dans des
hôtels ça coûte un peu moins cher mais
ça coûte très très cher et
l'augmentation des dépenses de personnel
liées aux assistants familiaux étaient
effectivement dus à cette arrivée de
migrants qui nous est imposée par les
lois de la porte uniquement le fait
uniquement l'arrivée des mineurs
non-accompagnés entre venant de
l'étranger
on a aussi on n'a pas seulement ddd mn à
des mineurs non accompagnés
on a aussi des jeunes qui nous sont
confiés par la justice qui sont confiés
à l'aide sociale à l'enfance et aux
départements et qu'il faut mettre en
sécurité souvent dans les familles
d'accueil donc mais revenons sur
l'échangé et menace sur les huîtres en
voudrait bien terminé s'il vous plaît
juste un chiffre cette année 2021 1er
janvier 2021 jusqu'à aujourd'hui trente
jeunes se déclarant mineurs non
accompagnés ont tapé à la porte du
département
après évaluation par nos services il se
trouve que neuf seulement sont
considérées comme mineures
donc nous allons accueillir parce que
c'est notre obligation légale parce que
c'est notre obligation morale parce que
c'est notre obligation d'être humain
nous allons accueillir c'est neuf jeunes
migrants et nous allons leur proposer à
la fois la sécurité et un parcours de
scolarisation et de formation messieurs
des jo diakité mais oui oui je suis tout
à fait bien parce qu'une paire blandine
version c'est la notion même d'humanité
et puis neuf mineurs pour tout le
département
franchement est-ce que c'est là le
problème monsieur vote risque d'être
pauvre
on est passé de 135 migrants non
accompagnés en 2017 à 500 ha en 2018 à
685 en 2019
aujourd'hui vous nous parler des neuf
mais il ya eu ces 685 comblons b une
partie des des finances du département
avec un coup à plus d'un million 8 mai
et vous dirigez vous feriez comme enjeu
pour le limiter ce nombre si vous vous
dirigez cette assemblée on n'a pas la
place on n'a pas les structures pourra
pour accepter dé ces nouveaux arrivants
c'est tout et puis après faut vérifier
sont ils réellement mineurs moi j'en
doute et les familles d'accueil qu'ont
pu avoir ces jeunes certains se sont
posé aussi les questions et ça a
découragé beaucoup de familles sont très
fréquemment des vérifications sont
faites justement sur la place de fait
ces gamins ou ces jeunes en tout cas
monsieur gautier écouter à chaque
élection c'est la même chose on nous dit
que les finances sont bien gérées sont
sous contrôle tout va bien et à la fin
de chaque mandat on fait toujours le
même constat
un endettement qui augmente puisque il
augmentait sur le mandat des
infrastructures qui sont délaissés
c'était de 18 millions d'euros en 2014
sur les routes c'était 9 millions en
2020 comment voulez vous que nos routes
soient mieux entretenues on parle des
mineurs non accompagnés
on est passé de 80 milles en 2018 à un
million six en 2020 alors il s'agit pas
de d2 de se défausser de ne pas jouer
notre rôle bien entendu mais il faut
être beaucoup plus efficace et beaucoup
plus performant pour juger de l'âge de
ces jeunes c'est très clair les collèges
pour la première fois sous ce mandat
les collèges ont été laissés à l'abandon
on a baissé de 31%
les investissements sur les collèges
entre 2014 et 2020 t1 comment voulez
vous que l'on donne un avenir à nous et
à nos collégiens le personnel alors le
personnel il est quelquefois montrés du
doigt mais moi je peux vous dire que le
personnel pour en rencontrer un certain
nombre il ne s'y retrouve plus il est
meurtri personnel il a une mission de
service public et il ne peut pas la
rendre cette mission de service public
parce qu'il n'en a pas les moyens
il galère c'est quand même fort de café
avec un début un département qui se dit
à gauche
il faut vraiment que le personnel il est
au coeur de notre action politique
il faudra un moment d'écouté avec eux en
début de mandat c'est clair et
n'oublions pas ce que j'ai lu dans la
presse que vous avez dit que vous
souhaitiez remettre à niveau les
finances et associer les agents de la
collectivité en ce sens concrètement ça
veut dire quoi vous allez leur dire
qu'il faut travailler plus vous allez le
jeu les salaires qu'est-ce que vous avez
choisi sur la très clair je vais
éclaircir sur les dépenses de
fonctionnement ses 35 millions d'euros
que nous dépensons là où d'autres
départements de même strate ne le
dépensent pas 35 millions on se pose
souvent la question de savoir s'il faut
aller au bout de la cité muséal 35
millions ces trois sites et muséal je
garantis que les autres départements il
se poserait pas la question
le personnel s'est plus vince +23 7% par
rapport toujours à cette même strate
les agents y en a trop annan a su a dit
lui même devant les agents qu'il était à
la tête d'un département de six cent
mille habitants
si on regardait le nombre d'agents
comment font les autres départements
allons voir comment ça se passe
serions nous plus plus bête
où nos agents serait-il moins courageux
je ne crois pas ils ont envie de
travailler
donc il faudra avoir un moment d'échangé
avec eux eux connaissent le
fonctionnement de l'intérieur et le rôle
d'un président c'est de les rassembler
et fédérer autour de lui
c'est de cette dynamique vous serez de
saison il ya trop d'argent au
département honnêtement je n'ai pas la
compétence comme ça je ne suis pas élu
pour le moment pour un pour en juger
je crois que j'ai déjà répondu à cette
question a très bien juste derrière qui
trouve qu'on parle de la session il ya
également cette notion va dire des
grands projets vous avez parlé de la
cité muséal ou pourrait parler de magny
cours les grands projets stop ou encore
j'ai envie de vous dire monsieur ces jo
je pense qu'il faut plutôt mettre en
place des projets d'abord qui parle du
territoire des idées des demandes des
chefs d'entreprise des artisans des
commerçants qui ont besoin effectivement
d'être écouté et d'être accompagnés dans
leur projet ça existe déjà il ya des
notamment des prêts à taux zéro continue
en place par le dans le département pour
les créateurs d'entreprises bien j'en ai
parlé il ya beaucoup d'agriculteurs de
paysans qui ont des projets de
transformation je pense qu'il faut aider
ces gens là à travailler ensemble au
niveau
le président macron a beaucoup parlé
pendant la crise due qu'au vu de la
nécessité de relocaliser l'économie
notre pays a beaucoup perdu en autonomie
beaucoup de productions se font à
l'étranger et nuisent à notre
indépendance économique et à la création
d'emplois donc je pense que un
département comme maniaque peut aussi
être adapté pour accueillir des petites
et moyennes entreprises les petites ces
magnifiques commanda département peu le
peut l'amener peu les dessins moi je
pense qu'il faut avoir une politique
extrêmement accueillante pour les chefs
d'entreprise il faut être attentif aux
porteurs de projets locaux
il faut mettre en place pourquoi pas des
appels à projets et il faut créer tout
un environnement social culturel
économique qui soit favorable à ce qu'on
appelle l'attractivité de la nièvre
monsieur gautier cette attractivité
l'année vous pouvez me rejoindre
oui oui j'ai fait une proposition tout
leur jeu là je renouvelle il faut qu'on
s'appuie sur les chefs d'entreprise qui
auront des réseaux et et savent là où
les difficultés qu'ils ont pu rencontrer
eux mêmes pour s'installer et comment
comment les lever mais enfin développer
l'attractivité
nous avons alors sur les sites et musées
elle c'est très clair ça coûterait trop
cher maintenant de cesser par contre on
a commencé à 2 2 au 3 millions d'euros
on est passé à 12 maintenant on est à 15
notre position si nous arrivons aux
affaires c'est stop on va pas ça sera
pas l'explosion de on n'en a pas les
moyens
et de toute façon si on n'est pas
capable de remettre à niveau nos
finances départementales
c'est pas la peine d'espérer avoir des
projets très clairement je crois qu'il
faut avoir le courage de dire la vérité
ou nivernaise et haut nivernais
il ya un travail titanesque qui se
présentent à nous et je ne vois pas qui
d'autre que d'asnières ensemble pour le
faire parce que nous sommes les seuls à
pouvoir incarner une alternance on en
arrive maintenant vers la fin de cette
émission on va donc passer à vos
conclusions à 5,1 d'entre vous dans un
ordre qui a été tiré au sort juste avant
de cette émission au va débuter avec
carole boirin avant que vous preniez la
parole on va tout d'abord montrer
puisque vous êtes candidature le canton
de nevers 3 apparaissent donc sur votre
écran donc les binômes qui se présente
face à vous un divers centre d'un des
amis de monsieur gautier on va dire le
binôme formé notamment par williams et
jo ici présents et un binôme
rassemblement national carole boirin 7 à
vous vous avez 50 secondes alors nous
souhaitons l'alternance quoi qu'il en
soit nous souhaitons l'alternance le
parti socialiste règne depuis 60 ans et
les situations la situation économique
est catastrophique dans la nièvre
situation économique situation sanitaire
situation à tout point de vue la
situation de la situation de la nièvre
est très difficile à l'heure actuelle ce
que nous souhaitons c'est rétablir les
finances c'est la première chose à faire
avec une diminution de la dette
aujourd'hui à 225 millions d'euros et
qu'il n'a cessé d'augmenter depuis 40
ans un rétablissement des finances
départementales avec une diminution des
dépenses de fonctionnement la tour
économique de la région parce que
j'entends beaucoup de choses sur la sur
l'atout économique de la nièvre certes
mais nous ne pouvons pas exister sans la
région c'est la région qui a la
compétence économique le parti
socialiste à l'heure d'aujourd'hui ne
s'est pas appuyé sur la région pour
rapporter dans la nièvre les
financements dont nous avions besoin
pour la développer économiquement et
cet atout là qu'il faut joindre à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui c'est fini pour
vous mesdames voir on va passer
maintenant à jean-luc gauthier je
rappelle que vous êtes donc candidat sur
le canton de guérini idem que pour les
autres candidats on va voir les trois
binômes qui se présente face à vous un
du rassemblement national de lièvre
écologie et solidaire et puis un de la
majorité sortante monsieur guti est à
vous chères concitoyennes chers
concitoyens les 20 et 27 juin prochain
vous désignerez vous conseillers
départementaux pour les six ans qui
viennent
le conseil départemental c'est la seule
collectivité qui vous accompagne tout au
long de votre vie votre mobilisation est
votre vote est donc important si comme
moi vous voulez une jeunesse mieux
accompagner dans nos collèges si comme
moi vous voulez que nos jeunes trouvent
du travail dans notre département
si comme moi vous voulez avoir un
meilleur un meilleur accompagnement au
niveau de la santé si comme moi vous
voulez que nos agriculteurs soient
considérés et accompagner pour produire
mieux
si comme moi vous souhaiter que nos
entreprises trouvent des conditions d'un
développement régulier dans notre
département
si comme moi vous souhaiter que nos
anciens puissent rester à domicile
aussi longtemps qu'il le souhaite si
comme moi vous vous saouler avoir des
routes en meilleur état
si comme moi vous voulez enfin que la
nièvre deviennent attractive et si comme
moi vous voulez que les élus s'unissent
pour travailler ensemble au
développement de notre département
alors faites voter et voter pour la
nièvre ensemble des équipes composées de
m et de remercier de seconde et a fini
par oublier jamais on va passer
maintenant donc à monsieur séjour
monsieur saison je le rappelle vous êtes
candidat donc sur le compte de nevers 3
le même que celui de madame boira on va
donc revoir à nouveau les noms des
binômes qui se présente face à vous dans
ce canton et à partir de maintenant vous
avez donc 50 secondes c'est à vous la
crise du coc vide a montré l'importance
des services publics et de la solidarité
le département et la collectivité qui a
en charge les grandes compétences
sociales et l'éducation notamment
travers les collèges nous voyons des
candidats du rassemblement national
parachuté dans tous les cantons des
départements qui n'ont rien de concret
rien de précis à proposer nous voyons
une majorité qui est calquée sur celle
du président macron c'est à dire une
des candidats pardon qui est calquée sur
celle du président macron la république
en marche
divers droite nous nous proposons plus
agriculture bio dans les cantines plus
de production locale des médecins
salariés plus de moyens pour les
personnes âgées et pour les ehpad en
envisageant notamment le retour en régie
publique mme hersman d'ehpad
contrairement à ce qui se pratique à
nevers la rénovation thermique des
collèges pour agir notamment contre le
réchauffement climatique
merci on va passer maintenant à blandine
de la porte vous êtes candidate sur le
canton de la charité-sur-loire nous
excuser moi d'abord si je suis trompé
vous éviterez numéro 5 numéros 4 donc ce
monsieur d'amis à boudry excusez-moi
candidats sur 9 vers 2 on va voir
également docly bino qui se présente
face à vous sur ce canton et à partir de
maintenant et bien vous avez 50 secondes
pour conclure monsieur beaudry les
élections pour le conseil départemental
de la nièvre ont le corps le compteur à
zéro pour la première fois depuis plus
de 50 ans
trois pôles distincts dans la nièvre
s'offre à vous
ladite droite qui soutient la politique
d' emmanuel macron au niveau local et
national la gauche de françois hollande
et de jean luc mélenchon qui déçoivent
mandat après mandat et le localistes les
patriotes du rassemblement national que
je représente ce soir nous n'avons
jamais dirigé le parton le département
nous n'avons aucune complicité avec les
décisions passées et présentes et nous
vous proposons des hommes et des femmes
avec des idées nouvelles
nous vous demandons votre confiance
laissez-nous vous montrer de quoi nous
sommes capables
la politique du pire est déjà en place
les temps sont révolus
finie l'époque où même une chèvre avec
une roseraie liar's réélu ce baudrier
merci beaucoup et enfin sept fois dont
l'audit de la porte cette phase est
vraiment à vous je rappelle donc
candidate sur le canton de la charité
sur loire les binômes qui se présente
face à vous dans ce compte on s'affiche
actuellement à l'écran et à partir de
maintenant et bien vous avez 50 secondes
pour conclure merci juste je voulais
rappeler
aux téléspectateurs ni vernet et qui
nous regardent que l'équipe sortant
c'est celle qui a innové c'est celle qui
a fait du marault une terre
d'expérimentation
c'est celle qui s'est engagé dans la
participation citoyenne c'est celle qui
soutient territoire zéro chômeur de
longue durée c'est celle qui a mis en
place une mutuelle départementale qui
permet au plus grand nombre d'accéder
aux soins c'est celle qui a mis en place
une stratégie d'adaptation au changement
climatique
faisant de notre département un
département pilote sur la question donc
je voudrais juste rappeler aux nivernais
que les candidats et les candidates de
vivre la nièvre dont certains sont
expérimentés et de nombreux nouveaux
visages
ce sont les candidats les mieux placés
pour faire gagner la nièvre nous faisons
le pari de la nièvre d'une réalité
innovante c'est terminé c'est terminé
pour vouloir de la porte serviettes
merci à vous cinq en tout cas d'être
venus débattre
bien évidemment les élections ça
continue sur france 3 ne manquez pas
mercredi soir le grand débat des
régionales à partir de 21h pour ce qui
est des départementales et on se
retrouvera nous lundi prochain où on
s'intéressera cette fois à la côte d'or
et à la saône-et-loire merci bonne
soirée à vous j'ai envie de dire même
bonne nuit de l'horreur
[Musique]